on est maintenant avec le docteur karl
weiss président de l'association des
médecins britanniques aubry biologiste
perdons infectiologues du québec
monsieur faes bonsoir alors aujourd'hui
nouvelle importante à québec le
gouvernement qui a décidé d'un retour à
l'école primaire les garderies aussi
d'un déconfinement progressif
vous en pensez quoi vous de de cette
décision-là de québec
c'est une décision vous savez où on
devait arriver à un moment donné c'est
une décision qui est bonne dans le
contexte qu'à un moment donné il faut
sortir du des compliments qu'on peut pas
garder éternellement tout le monde
enfermé surtout les plus jeunes enfants
vous avez vu que l'association des
pédiatres du québec s'est clairement
positionné en faveur de faire retourner
les enfants les coques sur deux raisons
et c'est des gens qui sont probablement
les plus compétents dans le domaine donc
il faut savoir aussi qui a cédé risque
on doit courir mais c'est des risques
calculés
c'est à dire que les enfants de façon
générale ont très peu de chances de
faire une maladie très sérieuse
donc même si attrapé le virus c'est peu
probable qu'il soit très malin et des
risques quand même mais vous savez quand
vous prenez votre auto le matin il ya
toujours un risque quand on s'en va
manger il ya un risque dans tout ce
qu'on fait dans la vie il ya un risque
donc c'est toujours un risque calculé
et il faut le voir comme ça s'il faut
voir un risque différents en un risque
individuel d'un risque populationnelle
donc sur l'ensemble des enfants qui vont
tourner en garderie et aux primaires la
chance d'avoir une maladie sévère ou
d'avoir une complication majeure est
très faible et la majorité des parents
de ces enfants là sont des gens
relativement jeunes devraient donc les
gens qui ont des enfants de primaire en
garderie et donc sont eux-mêmes à peu
d'exceptions près encore une fois peu à
risque de faire des complications
sévères
donc il faut s'imaginer un réservoir où
on va commencer à vider le réservoir
goutte à goutte
si les gouttes à gouttes ça marche puis
on est capable de pas votre problème
d'inondation
on va ouvrir un petit filet d'eau si le
petit filet d'eau fonctionne on va être
capable d'ouvrir plus le robinet d'avoir
de l'eau encore plus importante qui sort
le fameux robinet le fameux robinet du
docteur arruda
j'aimerais vous entendre dr veille sur
la question de l'immunité de groupes
collective
est-ce que c'est réaliste de croire qu
éventuellement on pourrait atteindre une
immunité collective parce que là on
n'est pas là on est à peine 1 6 7%
d'immunité et on le sait on ne sait pas
finalement où on est première chose dont
on ne sait pas du tout alors je pense
que n'importe qui avance des chiffres d'
avance des chiffres qui sont compris on
pourrait chacun avançait un chiffre
différent et on n'aurait probablement
pas tout à fait tort
alors ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est est ce qu'on va se
rendre à 60% 70% quelques mois la
probabilité est que non mais la
troisième chose c'est qu'à partir du
moment où il ya un certain nombre ont
déjà fait la maladie l'un risque d'avoir
une je dirais des problèmes sévères à un
moment donné surtout à l'automne contre
les écarts vont recommencer les
secondaires les universités le sujet il
va falloir aussi retourné 1-1 et quand
c'était travail plus importante
peut-être une réouverture des frontières
à un moment donné je parle pas des
frontières au niveau international mais
en amérique du nord
tout au moins 20 personnes ont commencé
entre les provinces alors c'est ça mais
tous en tout ensemble de faire un état
risque de se retrouver avec plus de cas
donc s'il ya déjà des gens à peu
protégés ça va ça m'a facilité un petit
peu tout ce plan de réouverture on a
doctor reste encore beaucoup de
questions des téléspectateurs ce soir je
commençais que la première on parle de
la nécessité d'obtenir une immunité
collective soit
pourtant il semblerait qu'on ne sache
pas pour combien de temps une personne a
bien été effecté est immunisée doit-on
craindre une deuxième vague de
contamination alors il ya deux questions
là dedans
le fait de savoir pour combien de temps
les gens sont immunisés ou pas immunisés
c'est indépendant je pense certain poids
de la deuxième vague
c'est un peut relier dans le sens que ce
qui va nous vraiment nous dire et on l'a
pas eu de des données chinoises on n'en
a pas pris ça de la chine donc il ya
beaucoup de données qui sont sortis de
chine qui n'étaient pas des données très
très fiable et un peu je pense on est en
train de faire notre apprentissage mais
ce qu'on va voir c'est que les gens qui
ont été vraiment contaminé durant cette
période si les gens qui ont eu un cas
prouvé de comics 19 on aura fait un test
il était malade et cetera puissance en
sortie
ces gens là bas on va voir si à
l'automne dans six mois dans huit mois
dans neuf
moi est ce que ces gens là vont serez
affecté est-ce qu'ils vont avoir
beaucoup seraient infectés six personnes
parmi ce groupe là serait un fait à ce
moment là on va pouvoir dire qu'on a une
immunité qui est durable et probablement
protectrice et en plus de 7,6 là on va
beaucoup amélioré le raffinement de
allait déterminer si les gens des
anticorps protecteurs ou pas parce qu'il
ya déjà des compagnies qui travaillent
là dessus
bon maintenant autre question doctoresse
d'où vient l'optimisme à propos de la
disponibilité d'un vaccin pour la coved
19 d'ici 18 mois on entend souvent sans
à 18 mois 2 ans comment est ce qu'on
évalue ce délai ce que ça vous semble
raisonnable ça pour trouver un accent
alors je ne sais pas s'il faut être
optimiste il faut surtout être réaliste
la seule chose c'est que si vous parlez
d'une maladie normale
la réponse est non mais il faut
comprendre qu'à peu près tout le monde
sur la planète toutes les compagnies
pharmaceutiques tout ce qui peut en voir
qu'un institut étatique fait de la
recherche
tout le monde est concentré sur une
seule chose la colite 19
donc on n'a jamais mis quasiment dans
l'histoire pourtant le moyen en si peu
de temps pour essayer de trouver soit
des médicaments soient des vaccins par
rapport à une maladie quelconque même
pour le vih ça s'est pas déroulée aussi
rapidement donc pratico pratique si tous
les moyens sont mis en oeuvre pour un
virus qui quand même relativement stable
on va dire
c'est à dire contrairement à d'autres
virus est plus difficile de faire des
vaccins regardez l'exemple vih
on est tour n'a toujours pas de vaccin
même si ça fait 40 ans alors que là je
vous dirai ce serait raisonnable de
penser que d'ici peut-être 12 à 18 mois
on aurait peut-être est-ce aussi est ce
si possible docteur vice qu'on ne trouve
jamais de vaccins pour les coronavirus
pour la cause est de 19
c'est une possibilité c'est aussi tout à
fait et bien sûr c'est une possibilité
on trouve pas un bon vaccin on trouve un
vaccin avant b qui donne une protection
qui est très limité et j'entends power
bien tout à fait c'est un point au 6 mai
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
vaccin même s'il va être disponible
il y aura une question de production de
vaccin est ce qu'on va être capable de
produire des centaines de millions de
doses en combien de temps de dons ou
espérant être produite parce que vous
imaginez que si les doses sont produites
dans un pays x y ils seront peut-être
pas très enchanté à l'exporter ailleurs
avant d'avoir d'abord immunisés leur
population donc il va avoir toutes
sortes de deux disques y en ait
et par rapport à ça ont très rapidement
dr weiss dernière question le virus
peut-il rester actifs plus longtemps
celle est combattu par quelqu'un ayant
un système immunitaire fort
non pas vraiment on aura été ça dépend
pas du système une terre formes parfois
ça dépend du c'est que souvent le virus
séné relativement maîtrisé entre
guillemets assez rapidement mais quand
on voit des gens très très malade c'est
souvent que leur propre système
immunitaire à un petit peu perdu son
pôle effet autant de dommage si vous
voulez par sa réaction que le virus lui
même
donc c'est pas une question du système
terre fort ou faible
c'est une question qui est beaucoup plus
complexe où il ya le système immunitaire
mais il ya aussi il faut le contrôle du
système immunitaire qui intervient là
dedans mais dr weiss merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu encore une fois aux
questions des téléspectateurs c'est très
précieux comme collaboration parce qu'on
en a beaucoup des questions et on n'a
pas fini de se poser merci infiniment et
bonne soirée
on fait plaisir